les sciences avec une première mondiale
la naissance d'un bébé médicament il a
été conçu dans le but de prélever des
cellules souches et de les transplanter
sur son frère aîné qui souffre d'une
maladie rare une technique évidemment
controversée elle est autorisée qu'aux
états unis
sophie mais elle avant même de venir au
monde
ce bon choix avec un destin tout tracé
sauver son grand frère atteint d'une
forme rare de leucémie
car charlie quatre ans en un donneur
compatible a une espérance de vie qui ne
va pas au delà 30 ans pour avoir une
chance de guérir leur fils les parents
des britanniques ont choisi d'avoir
recours à un donneur compatible et cela
ne pouvait être qu'un frère ou une soeur
de charlie ils ont donc dû procéder à
une fécondation in vitro accompagné de
ce qu'on appelle un diagnostic
préimplantatoire il s'agit de
sélectionner parmi les embryons fécondés
depuis trois jours les seuls qui seront
compatibles avec les chromosomes du
petit garçon malade l'embryon peut alors
être implanté dans l'utérus de la mère
et neuf mois plus tard lors de
l'accouchement
les médecins récupère le sang du cordon
ombilical riche en cellules souches
cellules capables de réparer les
cellules malades charlie cette procédure
est interdite en grande bretagne comme
en france pour des raisons éthiques et
les parents ont dû se rendre aux états
unis pour contourner la loi
mais l'opération n'est pas sans risque
rien n'assure à 100% que charlie pourra
être sauvé et que son petit frère ne
développera pas la maladie